[7-58* Color 1970-1972 Interview with
Calhoun and Introduction of S102
Mice into Universes of Studies 122,123 CA 110
Minutes]
[58* Part 1 Color/Sound 1972, Fall Univ. 25,
Study 102
McGraw-Hill Interview Scenes Include Last
Survivors CA 5 minutes]
[Bill Roberts:] Two and a half years ago, we
found Dr. John Calhoun knee-deep in
mice,
in the mouse heaven he designed for the
National Institute of Mental Health
Animal Center near Washington.
Dr. Calhoun wanted to find out what would
happen to a mouse colony
given everything mice need except living
space.
The result was chilling.
Two and a half years ago, more than two
thousand mice were packed into Mouse
City.
Today, a tiny handful of survivors huddles in one
corner of the city.
Dr. Calhoun explains what the
overcrowding did to Mouse City’s
inhabitants.
[Dr. John B. Calhoun:] The last thousand animals born never learned to develop the social behaviors.
They never learned to be aggressive, which is
necessary in defense of homesites.
They never learned to court; there was no
mating.
Being no mating, there were no progeny
and the older animals uhh, whose behavior
was already becoming disrupted, they
eventually reach to, an age too old to
reproduce.
And so it was all left up to these last
thousand or so, who we call the beautiful
ones,
because, not engaging in any stressful
activity and only paying attention to
themselves,
they groomed themselves well so they
look uh, very fine specimen.
But from that point on, which was about
the time that you were here two and a half
years ago,
this reproduction totally ceased and the
animals have just aged and died.
[Roberts:] At least one human group, the
Ik tribe discovered in Africa by Dr. Colin
Turnbull,
has gone through a similar, terrible
process, according to Dr. Calhoun.
[Dr. Calhoun:] The two conditions that they
went through was that there was a
decision
on the then-colonial government to make
a wildlife preserve of this big valley
which was their home, they’re
hunter-gatherers.
They were moved up onto the mountain
side and gathered together in much higher
density.
Instead of being spread out in small
groups, they were all placed in one place,
and also required to engage in an entirely different way of life,
in which their social roles, the whole...
everything they'd learned how to do had
no meaning.
Under those conditions, the social
behavior broke down.
They began living, they still lived together
but their activities were directed towards
themselves.
Everything you would think that’s human
disappeared.
[Roberts:] Perhaps the most chilling
conclusion from his Mouse City studies,
says Dr. Calhoun,
is that once this change in social behavior
occurs, it apparently cannot be reversed.
[Dr. Calhoun:] It's this fact of apparent
irreversible phase shifts that gives some
of us
particular concern over the fate of the human situation.
Because we see worldwide, the breaking
down of social roles, the increase in
contact
will result in the breakdown of social roles, because there are too many people.
This might lead to an overriding of our
controls of our total culture and would be
set into a process which would either fix
us rigidly forever into some sort of
global tribalism without any adaptation
to change,
or there would result, perhaps eventually,
some decline very much like we’ve seen
here,
but postponed somewhat.
[Roberts:] Dr. John B. Calhoun, with a very
sobering look at a possible future for us.
Bill Roberts from the National Institute of
Mental Health Animal Center near
Washington.
[59* Part 1(CONTD) Color 1970 April 1 ca
UDN:892 Univ. 25, Study 102,
Carl Coleman, Time-Life Interview, CA 30
Minutes]
[Background sounds and voices]
[Carl Coleman:] Dr. Calhoun, why do we have
to make decisions now
on our population control?
[Dr. Calhoun:] Well, the population's a
very interesting one.
There’s a lot of talk about a population
explosion.
Well, there's no population explosion,
at least not quite yet, and never has been,
or you might say there's always been a
population explosion.
If we go back to about forty thousand
years ago, uhh there were perhaps
four and a half million people on earth.
It had been not...many fewer than this
for the previous
two million years of man's evolution.
And then suddenly the numbers began
to increase,
and perhaps a little crude drawing here
will uhh show this.
These are in millions now.
And this is one, ten, a hundred million, one billion, and we go up above here.
And if we take a time scale here, an
inverse log, we go back to a hundred
thousand years ago.
And we go back to, we’ll make
this then to ten thousand years ago,
to one thousand years ago, one
thousand years ago.
Then a hundred which is one-tenth,
to one year, from sometime in the future.
So these are in time, in thousands of
years, and if we look at population growth
in this way, starting back about forty
thousand years ago...
population starting at about here, has
gone roughly in this direction.
Now this is a rather complex curve, it’s the
Von Foerster curve, but simply said,
starting here
at forty thousand years ago, it took about
twenty thousand years, umm about twenty thousand years
for the population to double.
Then the next doubling required about ten thousand years.
Then each doubling, five thousand years 'til the
next doubling, twenty-five hundred and so on.
[Coleman:] What doubling are we in
now, Doctor?
[Dr. Calhoun:] We’re in the tenth doubling
and the eleventh doubling.
[Coleman:] Is that the final one?
[Dr. Calhoun:] Well pretty near, it might be.
The final doubling, starting shortly after the next, way up here.
We’re up in here, scale about right, uhh in
which the world population might be of the
order
of four and a half billion now, people, would
require only twenty years to double.
So starting from twenty thousand years for
the first doubling up to about twenty
years,
if this historical process continues.
So we’re back here a little ways from that,
not very far from early in the next century.
[Coleman:] Can it be mathematically
projected, Doctor, on a calendar year
perhaps,
when the population reaches the point
where it outstrips our natural resources,
our power supplies, our food supplies.
[Dr. Calhoun:] When you say
mathematically this is what Von Foerster
did...
Projecting this age-old trend, not age-old,
forty thousand years, rather short time.
If this trend continued, you would have
instantaneous doubling, but we know
that's impossible, and thus the critical
question is that something is going to
happen,
that man will be different from the start of
man.
And this is where man started about forty
thousand years ago as a cultural animal.
Not as a biological animal, he went
considerably back in time below that.
But if beginning this new process
where he quote, now is the only animal
who could really control his numbers,
that is to keep enlarging them,
which is increasing his own potentiality by
so doing.
And this is continued until now we hit a
critical point here, where this process
can’t continue.
And so from this time forty thousand years
ago, to early in the next century,
defines what we call man.
And man ends at this point, 'cause there
are a lot of bodies around,
he’s going to have to be something quite
different than what he has been
historically.
And so one thing that he could do and
we’re certainly capable
of doing it, is keep reproducing.
So that’s one choice.
And another choice that we have,
early in the, which will have to be in effect
by early in the next century, is if he can stabilize the population.
One, he can keep going not very much
longer.
Above nine, well I haven’t got this, see.
This would have been at nine billion, I
haven’t quite gotten my figures here to
double to nine billion.
This is the end point if we, if the number
of children per adults
continues as it's been in the past,
it would be about nine billion people
at this point.
If we begin slowing down so that the
population can stabilize, which is the
ecological model
as we’ve tried to for wildlife management
to maintain a stable population,
then, with fewer children, we might keep
the, at this level we have seven and a half
billion.
Another critical point here is how many adults.
Ideally uhh, there should be, at this upper
optimum,
three and a half billion adults in order to
make most effective
the network of people communicating with
people.
However, if we go on the third, there's a
third choice,
and this is the population will begin slowly
to decline.
And if we go towards that goal, we would
have at that point
roughly about 6.3 billion total people.
With less than, considerably less than two
children per family.
[Coleman:] Doctor what do you think now of the stress of our environmental
problems,
trying to solve them?
Should government, the politicians pay
more attention to this problem, do you
think?
They’re all interlaced, it isn’t that simple.
[Dr. Calhoun:] Well, the problem, the
environment is just one problem
which we’re focused on now, and this may
be a real trap because we only look
at the physical, biological aspects of our
surroundings.
Where if we focused instead, on what is a
much more essential comprehensive
problem,
and this is evolution and the designing of
evolution.
In fact, we like to say that, uhh, we are
revolutionists here,
but a particular kind of revolutionist that
you could now spell differently.
Now we all know what this symbol is, this is prescription, but uhh,
[Sound of chalk writing on chalkboard]
so we are concerned with the prescription
for evolution of the design of the future,
the design of evolution. So we’re
revolutionists.
[Murmuring in background]
[Coleman:] Well doctor, why are we falling
into a trap, paying so much attention to
environment?
[Dr. Calhoun:] Well. We are in an
environmental crisis, there’s no question
about it.
The concern of the government in this
question is good.
The even greater concern, particularly at
the college level
and the environmental teach-ins that
are underway during April of this year
are extremely good movements, but they
may be a very deathly trap.
For this reason, that is, if we can focus
just on the good environment,
the biological environment, the physical
environment, we will miss a great deal of
what man is or could be.
With a concern for increasing human
potentiality, and again we like to say
we’d like to put mental, as in human capacity,
back in environmental.
And this is what we’re all about...
and we could set a trap, see.
The trap we’re setting here is we’re
looking at the environment on the
strictly biological model and not a man-
future evolutionary-directed model.
If we can develop a stable population
in which everything becomes fixed,
it’ll be unchanging over time, and now
we’ll be back in a global tribal situation.
Sure we might survive for millions of
years, but we aren’t going anywhere,
we’re like the lungfish in Lake Manyara,
who in this same situation,
they’ve handled it very effectively.
Whenever stresses come along, they
encapsulate themselves in a mud ball
and wait out the dry period and then come
back when the environment
is back in a suitable condition.
So we could become lungfish and
evolution would essentially end.
[Coleman:] What is government or what should government be doing now?
Is it aware of this problem in your opinion, are
we doing enough?
We’re doing very little, aren’t we?
[Dr. Calhoun:] I think there’s not, I don’t
think it's necessarily leveled at the
government.
I think this is a, whatever comment that
could be made here is one of general
awareness,
of becoming involved in the design of
evolution,
the prescription for further evolution.
We have to have a long-time perspective,
both in the past and the future,
and where we may go.
And that, that the issue, the big crisis now,
is not when we think of environment
relating to number of people.
It's not number of people.
It's people times capacities of the average
individual or the total human capacity.
Now if we, we can choose, now
is the time for choosing a goal.
And this in part relates to numbers.
But it also pertains to whether we
are going to select, from what has been
the definition of man for the last
forty thousand years,
some aspect of this, one of these is what
we call human potentiality,
the capacities of the average individual to
understand, to develop new insights,
to communicate with his fellows more
effectively.
If that is a major overriding goal and is
selected, and we select,
and one of the necessities for that is
maintaining a changing environment,
which includes the numbers, and the only
way to do that now is to decrease
numbers.
So that if we choose the goal of gradually
going into declining population,
with increasing human potentiality, we’re
now at 1970.
The critical point is about seventy-five
years from now.
There's tremendous time lag in social
change.
I mean it's been only a very short time
since the Supreme Court ruling for
integration
and we’ve made lots of strides in some
ways and very little in others.
But this is a much, much more drastic
change,
and if you’re going to change numbers
towards declining population,
the whole attitude of people’s values, the
decisions, have to be made in a very short
time.
We’ve got, let’s say fifteen years, or
to 1984.
So in essence if we, we have about fifteen
years of grace or opportunity
that this crisis presents to us,
in which we can change our whole value
system, or not change the value system
but change the mechanism for changing
the value system.
It’s a meta-process.
If we don’t do it within this time, we will
probably be at, we will go into 1984...
[Coleman:] George Orwell.
[Dr. Calhoun:] in the Orwellian sense.
So this is why it's critical.
It’s the most, by this time, right now is
the most critical time since sometime
before when man made this discovery
which probably took him about fifteen
thousand years
to learn how to discover a new kind
of space, a conceptual world of ideas
and progressive development of ideas.
So that in the early primitive hunter group
they had about fifteen thousand years
to solve their impasse of when they were
stuck by the carrying capacity of
environment,
the physical environment.
Now we’re also stuck with a similar problem
and have about fifteen years.
So it's quite a burden.
And the future, the entire future of
evolution depends on the next fifteen
years.
The people here now, who are involved
now...
which is critical and uh, it’s a question of
involvement.
I’m an ecologist, ecologist/psychologist,
however hybrid, and it’s a question of
environment with involvement in the total
environment of physical and social,
that is the crucial question in our studies
here
which we use mice and rats and other
animals for.
And that’s where we bring into focus our
research, is on the question of
involvement.
And they’re bitten up and the one that's
bitten fails to run away.
There's one type of..
[Interviewer:] Okay doctor.
[Dr. Calhoun:] And this is one of the
types of lack of involvement,
of total withdrawal from the reality
of the environment,
that’s compatible with that species.
[Interviewer:] What, twenty-four hundred
mice in this enclosure?
[Dr. Calhoun:] There’s something of the
order, we don’t know exactly what it is
now.
It’s between twenty-two hundred and
twenty-five hundred mice,
that is bodies, moving bodies.
But there are really only uhh about a hundred
and fifty mice in here.
Real mice, that is mice who are in the
social swim.
All the others have been rejected in one
way or another.
[Interviewer:] What’s happened…
[Dr. Calhoun:] …reproductive behavior's
completely inhibited.
It’s inhibited because the la…it's inhibited
because the last few hundred...
maintained them as juveniles and
although they are now adults uh they no
longer
engage in aggressive behavior or in
reproductive behavior.
And we call them the beautiful ones because
they are so excellent physically,
they are unstressed.
Now I see one down here.
Most of these live in the apartment houses
and rarely come out, but I see one
who's taken temporary refuge in one of
the nesting material supply cans.
I’ll go over and pull him out, so that you
can see what a beautiful specimen this
animal is.
[Interviewer:] But as far as the mouse
is concerned he’s a nothing?
[Dr. Calhoun:] He’s a total nothing.
[Calhoun climbs into the enclosure.]
Now here he is lying, in the uh...you
going?
[Interviewer:] Go ahead doctor.
[Dr. Calhoun:] Here he is lying in the can.
It’s a place of temporary retreat.
He’s colored very few, practically no wounds,
he’s in excellent physical shape.
He has two or three nicks but compared to most
of the animals, he’s in excellent shape.
And these animals from previous study shows
that they are, are unstressed.
They’re just not here insofar as
involvement.
[Interviewer:] You started this
experiment with just a few mice
some twenty months ago...apparently
you’ve been able to dissect some?
Have you noticed any changes in tissue?
[Dr. Calhoun:] Well the major thing...
[Interviewer:] The stress.
[Dr. Calhoun:] The major thing, well
certain classes of these, for instance
comparing these males on the floor here
who are withdrawn.
They are highly stressed animals but
the stress comes from each other
because of the peculiar violence that they
exhibit.
Which leaves them as this animal, with
his tail all chewed up, but they do it to
each other.
These are highly stressed individuals.
On the other hand, the beautiful one
which I just showed you,
are very, extremely unstressed.
We've run the, Dr. Julius Axelrod has run the
assay of the enzyme which converts
noradrenaline to adrenaline as the basis
for this.
On the other hand, we’ve been removing
females from other populations just
terminated
and looking at their uteri, and for animals
up to a year of age who’ve come up in the
latter history
of the colonies, there’s essentially no
evidence of conceiving.
So they’ve, at this stage, this is part of
the over-living phenomenon.
And it's these individuals who are not
conceiving are the ones which are not
stressed.
They’re the beautiful ones who lack involvement.
So that’s the uh, the essential story of
what’s going on in our studies.
[Interviewer:] Have you been surprised
Doctor, about the results of this,
what you’ve learned so far?
Some twenty months ago did you think all
these things were going to happen?
[Dr. Calhoun:] Well, I had a slightly
different hypothesis
which held true only in the early stages,
and this was that the larger the space the
uh, smaller the ultimate population
density.
That’s proved not to be true,
but a second aspect of that hypothesis
was that the larger the space with
reference
to the number of colonizers, the slower it would
get started.
This has been true because the essential
analogy here is that when there are few
animals
as in this particular universe, a male, any
mouse when he was out would rarely
meet another.
Therefore, he identified with all of
his physical environment.
So his own ego boundaries extended out
to include all of these things
which he was committed to,
and therefore, any other animal coming
out and moving towards any portion of
that
would elicit anxiety and therefore
aggression.
And we have huge territories and this
is an essential formulation of territoriality.
So that in the larger the space, the more
likely animals develop territoriality,
the more extreme.
And this did inhibit initial reproductive rate
and so with a smaller, we have smaller
universes than this and they grew much faster.
They got started quicker.
So that’s another facet of this problem, that
that gradually washed out beyond a
certain level,
and uh then the population increased for a
while, fairly rapidly, and then it hit this
level at which animals
begin being rejected out into public space,
as the males living on the floor here.
The females are rejected but they just
don’t come out,
they stay back in the apartment houses.
[Coleman:] Doctor, one final question
here, as a human…
[Murmuring]
Dr. Calhoun, as a human being, after
going through this experiment,
what goes through your mind?
Are you worried about the future of mankind?
[Dr. Calhoun:] A pathological situation like
this gives us an understanding of what
may be going on
in the human situation, and what might go
on, and be catastrophic.
And what is really catastrophic and where
the real fear is,
is on a level where the mice and man are
extremely similar.
That is, the mice have programs, they're
like little computers, uh,
and this is basically genetic with a much
smaller element of learned behavior.
And too-high a contact rate disorganizes
the program so that it gets washed out.
So it’s disconnected or it doesn’t express
itself.
This is where you get the lack of involvement.
On a human level, we do have a much
more complex brain, it does get
programmed,
less by genetics, less by heredity than for
the mice, much more cultural,
but it’s just as subject to being
disorganized,
to having a program disorganized through
inappropriate sequences of contact,
too many contacts.
And so that we have this danger and part
of the danger
is that we don’t have an adequate
establishment.
Not a...
We’re now seeing, because the, quote,
establishment doesn’t provide
all appropriate channels, we should
destroy the establishment.
We need better establishment to allow
interrelationships to protect us from too
many contacts,
but to allow us for those contacts which
we do engage in to be more meaningful
for our own lives,
and for, meaningful to others in a
compassionate sense of each of us
being involved in helping the other to fulfill
his role.
We’ll have many more roles,
and this is where the notion of
compassion comes in,
in helping, each of us helping others to
fulfill their programs for development.
And so, we’re at this peculiar stage where
you’re highly optimistic, at the same time
highly pessimistic,
and you wish to throw your weight, intellectual weight, to moving towards the
optimistic side,
to opening up continuing evolution.
[7-60* Part 2 Color 1970, Jan. 27 to Feb.
17 UDN: 828 to 844
Introduction of Study 102 Male Mice into
Halsey Marsden’s Study 12, CA 65
Minutes]
[60* Color 1970 Jan. 27; UDN: 828 12
Aggressive Males from Study 102
into Univ. 12, Study 122 CA 15 Minutes]
[Mice are released from a box onto the
center of the floor. They scramble around
the area.]
[One mouse sits in the center of the
universe while others sniff around him.]
[Mice are fighting one another, scratching and rolling about.]
[A white mouse marked with red continues
to be aggressive with each mouse he comes near.]
[Camera zooms out, showing mice
scampering about the universe, seeming
to pursue each other.]
[Some of the non-aggressive mice have
retreated to corners and secluded areas of the
universe.]
[One black mouse is pursuing and fighting with others.]
[A white mouse with red marking is sitting
on top of a shelf where he is out of reach
of the others.]
[Most mice have retreated from the center
of the universe and are avoiding each other.]
[Two mice are seen fighting, chasing one another. They scuffle in a corner and continue to engage aggressively.]
[A white mouse crouching alone in an elevated area
remains there while the others fight on the floor beneath him.]
[One of the secluded mice leaves his
elevated perch and makes his way around the universe.]
[No other mice seem to be present.]
[He returns to his dwelling.]
[63* Color 1970 Jan. 29; UDN: 830
12 Solitary Withdrawn Males from Study 102
into Univ. 13, Study 122 CA Minutes]
[Mice are dropped into the center of
another universe. They spread out and make little contact with one another.]
[Mice are dropped off into the center of
[Some mice begin to engage with one another, showing aggression, while others remain apart.]
[One black mouse begins to initiate aggressive contact with others he encounters.]
[The aggressive behavior appears to spread through the population.]
[Some mice appear to seek refuge as others continue to fight.]
[Most contact is aggressive at this
point.]
[Time=0924]
[Fighting continues.]
[Some mice have remained apart from the others.]
[One mouse chases another who doesn’t
seem to want to come in contact with him.]
[The universe calms.]
[One mouse sits in his habitat eating, then peering over the side of his elevated retreat.]
[A pair of mice continue to fight with each other.]
[Roll 12 Univ. 13 0963]
[Only two mice remain in sight.]
[End Scene 0963]
[Time 0679]
[One mouse roams the universe alone.]
[A lab worker replaces the water container
on the side of the mouse universe.]
[A second water container is added for the
mice.]
[The lab worker makes sure the water is coming out of the container properly.]